Jennifer is with us in California hi
Jennifer how are you I'm doing a Miss
around here are you doing better than I
deserve what's up I am free when my
husband is 44 and we've been to the FPU
I've been through it twice and once as a
married couple I kind of lost my mana
Menem we were doing good up until about
two years ago then my husband went to
get a credit card to help build our
finances fall inside get house with the
next two or three years and everything
kinda like fallen from there we make
about 55,000 a year we have a combined
revoltin school full-time as well as
work full-time
we both have combined student loans of
$25,000 I have a car of $17,000 and
combined credit cards of just under
$8,000 and I feel so overwhelmed right
now um the other day my husband said
that he want he's been wanting to lift
hit on his Tahoe which will cost about
$8,000 she said she wins but on the
credit card then declare Bay Country and
I'm like and I'm so overwhelmed right
now I don't know what to do yeah well I
mean the two of you have to decide how
you're gonna live your life I can't
decide that for you you went through
Financial Peace University and you chose
not to do anything I taught you right so
I mean I've told you what to do I mean
you know that you need to do that stuff
you know I got to tell you it's stealing
your husband's a thief he's proposing
stealing to put to run up debt with the
full intention of turning around and
bankrupting it
that's thieving bankruptcy is not
thieving there's good people that get in
bad situations and I'm not mad at people
that file bankruptcy but if you tell me
I'm gonna run up a bunch of debt so that
I can file bankruptcy not have to pay
the bill that's the same thing as being
a bank robber you just stole that money
and so your husband has a lack of
character
that has to be addressed and you know
you guys went through Financial Peace
University but then you went to start
taking our credit cards to build up your
credit and you know I don't teach that
yeah it wasn't what you it wasn't what
you learned in there so I can only help
you if you will do the stuff we teach I
can't help you I can't participate in
your your craziness I mean you run
around doing all this crazy stuff and of
course it's not working so I think the
two of you need to sit down and talk
about how we're going to have a
high-quality life over the next thirty
years is it gonna be we're gonna run up
debts and file bankruptcy so we can put
a lift kit on a Tahoe that sounds like a
thirteen year old child so I mean you're
gonna have to address this immaturity
and address this lack of vision in your
household and the two of you are going
to sit down and decide are we gonna grow
up or not are we gonna be big people or
are we gonna be little people and
there's lots of 54 year old children so
you know because a child is based on the
way you act is based on your level of
emotional maturity your level of
spiritual maturity and your relation to
your ability to do relational things
with each other so I'm sorry you're
overwhelmed but of course you're
overwhelmed I mean you put your poured
seeds of weeds in your garden and then
of course you've got weeds in your
garden and so now what are we gonna do I
really want a weedy garden or we gonna
hoe it out are you gonna pull them up by
the roots and we're gonna stop doing
this stupid but stuff that isn't working
for you you know go back through
Financial Peace University both of you
get it with a good marriage counselor
because obviously you're not on the same
page get yourself in a good church
establish a vision for your household
for your future where do you want to be
in 30 years as a couple are we gonna
live thank God it's Friday oh god it's
Monday our whole lives
you've gotta side these things the neat
thing that will happen for you Jennifer
is the moment you decide both of you and
you're firmly committed to living a
better life a more mature
her life the moment you do that a lot of
the anxiety and the sense of being
overwhelmed will melt away the situation
will not have changed yet but just the
fact that you're gonna deal with the
situation what's killing you is you
think this is going to go on forever and
that's what that's where your anxiety
and your overwhelm comes from but even
in the exact same measure in once both
of you decide that's it I've had it
we're gonna have a vision where we
retire millionaires thirty years from
now and we're gonna get about the
business of causing those things to
happen and it probably does not involve
putting a lift kit on a Tahoe so that I
can bankrupt it oh my god so you know
you just have to stop and look at these
things and that's what you've got to
face